呃，这个就已经已经开始很少了。
好，因为ZEBRA就是实现这个方法论的这个厂商供应商。
好，注意啊，这两天我们这些全部都会讲，现在只是给大家循序渐进的在进入这个部位。
那当然了，POWER BI大家都知道了。
好了，这里面还是要再来讲一个很重要的东西，这个东西大家有没有知道？
这个这个这是什么？
这是在告诉你POWER BI和。
和亏叫Q，他们之间他们这个东西呢都有巨大的缺点。
他们的缺点是什么？
他们的缺点就是就是作为业财人员很正常要做，但是就是做不出来的东西。
因为在这些工具里面，他们只能告诉你什么发生了，以及昨天正在发生什么。
而作为业务和财务一定要做的一件事情，就是要做预算。
要做滚动预测。
好了，请问你怎么拿 power BI 做？
我告诉你，在技术上来讲，你理论上来讲，你做不了，为什么呢？
因为 power BI 所有的商业智能工具大家看到了吗？
叫做只读。
只读的意思就是你不能往里面 call 个数字，所以你没有学过 power BI 你也知道，就是你也现在也可以知道这么一件事，就是如果一个工具它只读，就是你只能查询，你只能去看图，那么你想要去做预算，你要往里面填数字呢，你
填不进去，所以呢，在这里面呢，在这里面其实在这个工业界，在上面的这一堆东西都被归纳叫做报表工具。
如果按照业财的术语的话，后面这个东西叫做做PLANNING的工具。
好了，那么现在问大家有没有有用过做PLANNING工具的同学，可以举个手。
有没有用过做PLANNING的工具？
你们肯定用过EXCEL吧，所以你都是用EXCEL来做。
PLANNING对不对？
所以这两天你将学习比EXCEL，你知道我为什么，你知道你们为什么没有用过PLANNING的工具吧？
在这个文件夹里面，在这个文件夹里面呢，给在这个文件夹里面注意啊，这个文件夹叫什么文件夹呢？
叫做呃魔力象限。
这个这个魔力象限呢，首先有一个叫做有一个这这个叫。
Gartner是世界最权威的咨询公司之一，它会对市面上的各种信息化的工具进行评估，所以基本上它评估的东西世界是比较认可的。
那么在这个象限里面呢，大家可以看到了，这个是微软排名第一，所以我们这两天就会学习世界最领先的商业智能工具。
好了，但是你们就是大部分人都只是知道这个象限图，但是你们知道吗？
还有一个象限图。
图还有一个象限图，这个象限图的这个名字叫什么？
大家看一看这个象限图的名字叫什么？
叫做财务 planning 的工具。
你知道谁是排名世界第一吗？
谁是排名世界第一？
好，我们看财务里面谁是排名第一，看见了没有？
你知道你们为什么没用过吧？
因为这里面没有一个是免费的，能听懂吗？
而且它不但不免费，而且非常贵，而且不能试用。
几乎所以，所以从某种角度来讲，一般来讲，只有不差钱的外企的总部才会买。
然后呢，因为你不小心进了这种公司，才会分一个license给你用，而且你可能还不会，还不如你用电子表格。
但是你要知道，人家是世界排名第一，世界排名第一是有道理的。
你不会用它，不不怪不怪它，怪你为啥？
谁让你世界第一，你不会呀。
那么大家都知道，这个我们初中就学过了，叫做生产工具代表了生产力的标志。
你的生产力的，你的生产力的高和低，取决于你到底会用什么工具。
而另外一个，你之所以不能够使用这些工具，取决于一件事儿，不是你知识不够，是你根本没想通这里面有些事儿。
好了，所以
那么问题来了，我们现在你看到的这个右上角的所有的做PLANNING的这个工具都要收很多的钱。
所以你要做PLANNING的话，你因为PLANNING没有个人去做这件事儿的，一定是企业，而且尤其是正规的大型企业，一定会去做PLANNING。
如果这个东西回归到中国的古语有一句话：孙子兵法第一章第一节是什么？
先胜而后求战。
所以大家一定要看孙子兵法十三章第一章第一节，先胜而后求战。
先胜而后求战的本质就是先做计划再打仗。
也就是说，他的胜不是因为打着打着打胜了，是因为他在打之前他就知道他赢了。
为什么打之前就只赢了？
因为做了planning。
所以从商业的角度来讲，商业的管理学之父、现代管理学之父叫什么叫什么商业的现代管理。
理学之父，第二次工业革命。
我们现在是第几次工业革命？
第四次工业革命是啥革命？
好，推荐一本书，一定要看这本书，叫做杰克特劳特定位。
第一次工业革命叫做泰勒的这个这个过程管理，第二次叫做现代管理的这个革命，这个引领者就是彼得。
德德鲁克现代管理之父，而彼得德鲁克所所做的这个目标管理是现在所有的企业都在用的。
那么这个东西就说的第一个事儿，就是你这个企业要定目标，要定目标你怎么去实现它？
那么你就是在做计划去实现它。
所以我我们现在我现在说的这些东西，是我们讲这个课的最重要的理论根基，就是我们不是瞎讲，注意啊。
你在问我老师我要学power BI的时候。
你会带着非常多的杂杂七杂八的想法。
为什么？
哎，老师，我为什么要学这个？
老师，因为我看到这个图很酷，我想我想把它做出来，我应该怎么做？
哎，老师，这个文件我要合并，怎么合并？
哎，老师，这个这个报表这个公式不会写，怎么写？
注意这些东西都是没有意义的。
什么东西有意义？
刚才我说的这才有意义，能能理解吗？
你问的东西很可能是一棵树的树叶，上面有根虫子怎么着？
你把这个树叶剪了扔了，不就不要了就行了。
这个树上有一万个树。
树叶，但是你没有找到这个树的树干。
而我刚才说的就是这个树干。
所以这门课为什么叫业财分析之道？
这个这个它的精华在于哪里呢？
就在于它解决商业分析的最本质的问题。
大家在工作问大家另外一个课题，问大家另外一个课题啊。
大家在工作之所以能拿到比较高的工资，你们认为你们跟公司交换的是什么？
用一个关键词回答我，这个关键词大家大家那个线上的同学也可以说这个关键词就是大家在拿工资，然后呢你的工资可能你的收入可能高可能低，因为你在公跟公司交换一个东西，因为你交换了以后公司才给你钱，这是我们挣钱的本质逻辑，第一性逻辑对不对？
那么问题来了，请问请回答你跟公司交换的是什么是什么。
大家想一想是什么？
这个关键词是什么？
写在公屏区。
我是什么？
你跟公司交换的。
我告诉你，这个关键词如果你以前不知道的话，你今天一定要把它记住。
价值是一个很接近的词，但是它太虚，它太虚。
因为你说，哎，我有价值不？
你有的，但是价值多少来？
所以这个词大家一定要记住，你跟你花钱买课，你希望跟老师交换的是啥？
哎，你有不是模板吗？
不是十个模板吗？
哎，你想跟老师交换的是啥？
你想一想，你花钱买了课，那么你交换的是啥？
哎，我希望你回答的东西是你看啊，你要回答说知识啊，我就喜欢听到这个答案。
那为啥了？
因为我讲了两天知识，你听不懂。
那你的事儿能能能能理解吗？
然后呢，你会说老师，我这花了钱没学会呀，没学会是你自己没学会呀，我已经讲完了呀。
所以你并不想交换知识，能听懂吗？
因为交我讲完了，那你想交换的是啥？
我告诉你这事儿，你要想不通的话，那你这个东西辛劳了半辈子，你都搞不清楚你在换啥，换换什么。
投投资回报回报，那我讲了两天，我觉得回报很大，你觉得回报不大。
好，注意啊，这两个字是非常非常重要的。
你看你要预习这个课了，你就肯定能回答对这两个字了。
业财分析之道叫面向什么的数据分析？
你们大家所有的人在互相交换的，其实只有一个东西，就是结果。
你弄了两天，然后呢，别人肯定会说哦，你学了两天，那结果呢？
结果啥也没学会。
哎，这就是结果，能听懂吗？
你跟老板汇报一个东西，哎呀，老板，我这个很辛苦，我在这做了做了做了做了做了。
但是你你有没有发现，有的时候这个有就是企业其实根本并不关注你有没有在公司谈恋爱，你今天中午有没有吃的好。
嗯，怎么着？
最近互联网上有一个很很沸沸扬扬的一个一个一个一个东西，是不是有一个叫什么的高高管？
是是是哪个哪个公司的高管，然后呢弄弄了一个什么抖音的视频，说他们公司的一个人怎么着了，这跟我有什么毛关系，你是来上班的。
这是哪个公司的？
那为什么其实从一方面吐槽归一方面吐槽，但是大家一定要明白，我们去跟别人交换的唯有一个事就是结果。
你想一想，纵使你在公司干了十年，有没有可能把你裁掉呢？
但是如果你跟老板说：‘我明年、我明天我可以给你一个结果’，他再想一想，所以你的价值是基于结果的。
所以这个是非常关键的。
所以有的时候你有没有这种情况？
就是你知道吗？
你不能给公司结果的时候，公司还给你发钱，你知道你在拿什么跟公司在交换吗？
时间就你你你你……
你讲完这一段，你就知道你数据分析你该学学什么了，以及你怎么学了。
比如说一个老板说，哎呀，你肯定跟老板说今年我想加加加工资，你跟老板说今年你要加工资，但老板并不想给你加工资。
但是呢，那个就是呢，他说你为什么这个项目没做好，然后呢，你说就是老板说这个项目你应该给我这个结果，但是你这个项目他说你没有做好，那么你会怎么样呢？
你不是生气。
记，老板在说你没做好东西的时候，你首先会干嘛？
狡辩，你是不是会解释一下？
你是不是会解释一下，能听懂吗？
你是不是会解释？
你解释就是希望他购买你的什么？
你解释就是希望他在购买你的理由，能听懂吧？
你知道吧，所以这这两个词你一定要学会，一个词叫结果，另外一个词叫理由。
而且你会你的人生，你也会给自己设定很多目标。
你说哎呀我要减肥，这就是结果。
但是呢，哎呀，但是呢，我今天我跟佐罗老师聊欢了，我要跟他吃一顿，这是理由。
所以你达不成你的结果，所以大家一定要明白，理由会变成你跟结果是理由跟结果是等价的。
所以你想一想，你一天拿出的结果多还是理由多？
当你的理由占到百分之八十的时候，你会发现。
你是被一种无形的力量推着走的。
但是如果说你一天能给自己提交百分之九十的、百分之八十的结果的话，你又是被一种力量推着走的。
但是大家想一想，一个公司它在往前推着走，你说它是不是要靠无数的结果往前推着走？
好了，那么现在问题来了，当你在做数据分析的时候，因为我们讲的这个东西，你看我应该去讲管理学的，但是你们在这儿也听了老板要听的了。
注意啊，我刚才讲的东西是老板评完了以后回来那个就是教育你们的那个素材。
就是，但是我们做数据分析的时候也是这样子的，请问在数据分析里面什么是结果？
什么是理由？
哎，你有没有发现财务的人有的时候他会跟跟业务去冷冰冰的，就是财务里面看到了一个数字，哎，你这个报销你没填对，你这个东西没弄对，你这个结果不对，你这个成本高了，你这个什么低了？
业务就是说，我那就是业务的解释，其实是希望财务能够认同他花的钱，或者他挣的钱有道理，或者是怎么着。
但是财务只看什么？
是不是只看结果？
好了，所以大家要明白这么一件事情，就是学数据分析的最高境界是面向结果的数据分析。
哎，你要去分析这个东西，哎，老师我做了一个饼图，对你也可以学这个，但是呢，那个一百块钱的课很多都会教你怎么做饼图。
但是我要教你们的是面向结果做数据分析，它的这个底层逻辑跟公司的经营是直接贯通的。
所以这是一个，这是一个完整的这个这个闭环。